[Musique]
une répétition de cérémonie sans fausse
note mais une véritable cacophonie à la
tête de l'état hier donald trump a
annoncé la réouverture partielle des
frontières le 26 janvier prochain pour
les voyageurs en provenance de plusieurs
pays
le secrétaire à la santé et aux services
sociaux m'a conseillé de supprimer les
restrictions applicables à l'espace
schengen au royaume uni à la république
d'irlande et à la république fédérative
du brésil
je conviens avec le secrétaire que cette
action est le meilleur moyen de
continuer à protéger les américains duke
au vide 19 tout en permettant aux
voyages de reprendre en toute sécurité
je juge par la présente que l'entrée
sans restriction aux états unis de
personnes qui ont été physiquement
présentes dans ces juridictions n'est
plus préjudiciable aux intérêts des
états unis
sauf que l'équipe de baden ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille
quelques minutes après la proclamation
présidentielle la futur porte-parole de
la maison blanche a contredit celui qui
est encore président pour 24 heures sur
la vie de notre équipe médicale
l'administration n'a pas l'intention de
lever ces restrictions le 26 janvier
en fait nous prévoyons de renforcer les
mesures de santé publique autour des
voyages internationaux afin d'atténuer
davantage la propagation du coc u19 avec
l'aggravation de la pandémie et
l'émergence de variantes plus
contagieuse dans le monde ce n'est pas
le moment de lever les restrictions sur
les voyages internationaux
un épisode qui reflète les positions
opposées des deux présidents sur la
crise sanitaire
donald trump à relativiser à plusieurs
reprises la gravité de la pandémie et ne
s'est pas privé de meeting pendant la
campagne alors que joe biden a d'ores et
déjà annoncé le renforcement des
protocoles sanitaires et l'obligation du
port du masque la décision de donald
trump a d'ailleurs de quoi surprendre
la pandémie fait plus que jamais rage
aux états unis qui compte près de 400
mille morts et où le seuil des 4000
décès quotidiens a été franchi plusieurs
fois ces derniers jours et les pays
visés par la levée de l'interdiction de
voyager aux états unis sont loin d'être
épargnés sans compter le variant
britannique qui se répand un peu partout
et a été détectée sur le sol américain
il y a trois semaines dans le colorado
façon de rappeler que le coc vie de 19
sous toutes ses formes ne connaît pas de
frontières
m